حاول ان انت تبقى صاحي طول الليل ما انت
مش غير ساعه واحده بس وتصحي عليا
انا مش عارفه استحمى
الفنانه امينه خليل اهلا بيكي على شاشه
العربيه
امينه دور نادين في الهرشه السابعه يمكن
الشخصيه احنا بنشوفها كل يوم بنت عاديه ما
فيهاش حاجه مميزه عكس مثلا دورك في مسلسل
قابيل ده بيبقى التحضير بالنسبه لك ده كده
اسهل ولا اصعب اهلا بيكي كل سنه وحضرتك
طيبه وكل متفرجين شاشه العربيه
دور نادين يبان ان هو اسهل بحكم ان هي بنت
عاديه
ومتوفر النموذج ده حوالينا ولكن في
الحقيقه هو اصعب بكثير علشان هي بنت عاديه
وفي نفس الوقت لازم يتقدم لها ولازم يتعمل
لها حقائق وواقع وكده
بالعكس انا انا يمكن ساعات بحس انه انه
اسهل لما يبقى عندك مش شخصيه في مسلسل او
في فيلم كاركتير مختلف جدا بقى عن اي حاجه
عشان بيبقى سهل انك
ان انت لبستي مثلا لبس مختلف انت كده
قطعتي شوط كبير جدا ان انت بتعملي مختلف
زي مثلا قابيل او زي زيزي او زي نظري مثلا
في جراند اوت انت زمنيه مختلفه فالكاريكتر
مجرد من وانت واقفه كده بس بتبصي عليه انت
كده قريتي رحتي في حته مختلفه نادين ما
كانش فيها ده علشان هي عادي لابسه جينز
وتيشرت زيها زي اي بنت تانيه ولكن هي فيها
حاجات سبيشل كثيره جدا في الشخصيه كل حاجه
داخليه ويمكن ده بالنسبه لي كان اصعب شويه
مش عايزه يوم من الايام من العيال دي تيجي
تقعد قدامي تقول لي استحمل لهم عشان
خاطركم انتم واشيلهم همي وزعلي وحسسهم
بتاني بضمير الكاتبه مريم نعوم بتقول ان
انت فكره مسلسل الهرشه السابعه بدات من
عندك كلمينا كده على الموضوع مريم جاتلها
مكالمه تليفون مني
حوالي من حوالي مثلا سنه ونصف قبل ما
المسلسل ده ينزل ااا الصبح بدري جدا كنت
نايمه وصحيت وجات لي الفكره
فكلمتها قلت لها مريم انا عرفت احنا
هنتكلم فيه انا عرفت المسلسل اللي احنا
هنعمله دلوقتي هي احنا انا عايزه اتكلم
على العلاقات الزوجيه والعلاقه اللي بتفشل
والامومه بس تكوني انت بتعالجيها بطريقتك
انت اللي هي شاطره فيها قوي اللي هي بتخلي
المتفرج يبقى قاعد بيقول ده انا الفكره
جات لي علشان انا لاحظت انه دي اسئله انا
بسالها لنفسي
اما بقعد مع اي حد بقعد مع صديقاتي البنات
نتعشى بره ولا ما بيجي لي مكالمه تليفون
من حد من اصدقائي متجوز او او كده انه ده
دائما نقاش محطوط على الترابيزه احنا
دايما بنتكلم في المشاكل الزوجيه وبنتكلم
فهو ايه اللي حصل فاما يبقى فيه
كم طلقات بتحصل في البلد فده شيء مهم جدا
احنا لازم نتناقش فيه امينه ملاحظ ان انت
لك تيم معين بتحبي تشتغلي معاه او بترتاحي
معاه مضبوط
كون ان في تيم احنا بنحب نشتغل مع بعض فده
ما كانش سهل خالص ان احنا نوصل له وده دول
جيلي دول ناس جيلي دول ناس جيلي اللي انا
فخوره بيهم وبحب اشتغل معاهم علشان الحمد
لله عملنا نجاحات حلوه قوي مع بعض فالواحد
لما يلاقي تركيبه حلوه بيحاول يمسك فيها
او نحاول ان هو يعني يعصرها يعني يحاول
يطلع احلى حاجه منها وبنرتاح قوي في الشغل
مع بعض
مش قادره خلاص مش عارفه اقف على رجلي يا
ادم
امال
يصحى انا تعبت مش عارفه اعمل ايه
وسايبني